there's so many new beauty products
being released all the time so we
gathered some of the most hyped to test
for ourselves
this is definitely one of those tick
tock made me buy it kind of products
this is the pseudo lab freckles kit it's
nothing like any other faux freckle
product i've ever seen you basically get
the freckle liquid which has a little
round brush in it and this little
toothpick looking thing that you use to
flick the liquid onto your face to give
you very natural looking freckles i knew
this was going to be a messy process so
i tucked a paper towel in my shirt and
just went at it
[Music]
am i prickly
right away i was obsessed with how the
freckles came out it's a strange and
kind of messy process but they do end up
looking really natural and cute but i
highly recommend you do this topless ore
with the paper towels stuffed into your
shirt
i wanted to try the milani conceal and
perfect smooth finish cream to powder
foundation because i saw people saying
this was a dupe for the kvd good apple
balm it's not that foundation is
literally a bomb so it's very slippy and
almost a little oily this milani one is
very thick and kind of dry i don't like
the texture of this at all i do feel
like this did a great job of covering
everything up because it is full
coverage but it definitely emphasized a
lot of my texture and i don't love how
it sat on my skin
this is the colourpop feather effect
styling brow wax i got both the clear
and the tinted versions also please
excuse my purple stained fingers this
product is a little strange i do think
that it gives your brows that fluffy
feathered look but i had to keep dipping
in over and over to get it to look the
way i wanted it to the texture of this
is just very odd like i had to keep
checking my brush to make sure that
there was anything even on it if you're
looking to this as a dupe for the abh
brow freeze i don't think this is one
the brow freeze has a way softer texture
and literally does freeze your brows
like they will not move this one has way
less hold and it doesn't feel like it
dries down also i feel like there's zero
difference in color between the tinted
and the clear so weird
now let's talk about the blush of my
dreams the melt cosmetics cream blush
light you guys i didn't know how this
was gonna go because i had already
powdered my entire face but i took a
risk and i just applied the blush on top
and oh my god this blush is so gorgeous
and it didn't mess up the foundation or
powder underneath at all
[Music]
i'm in love right now
and because i'm obviously a huge blush
lover i had to apply more and more and
more and it layered beautifully it's
totally buildable i fully understand now
why this has been sold out everywhere
[Music]
that's good
these are the denessa myrick's beauty
color fix eye cheek and lip cream
pigments these are multi-use pigments
and they come in a bunch of different
colors and finishes danessa myricks who
is a wonderful makeup artist always uses
these on her models to create like the
most beautiful looks so i was dying to
try them these pigments are no joke
literally one drop is all you need i
definitely use too much but i'm so
impressed not only by how pigmented they
are but how many ways you can use them i
use them for under eye corrector blush
eyeliner and lipstick once these dry
down they're definitely staying put this
was not my best makeup work but i was
just having a good time playing around
with these
minimal skin like makeup is kind of like
the norm now and this fenty beauty
eavesdrop blurring skin tint totally
makes sense for the time it's actually
way less liquidy than i imagined it to
be and as expected the coverage was
pretty minimal but the skin tint is
super buildable so i just added more
where i felt like i needed it highly
recommend using a brush if you want to
get the most coverage out of it the
finish is pretty nice and it does dry
down so you don't have to worry about
any tackiness i am just so not a skin
tint kind of person but this one gives
you that your skin but better look that
i think a lot of people would be into
[Music]
you